your mom's all right Jean we're back
oh we're recording now no recording yeah
hmm exciting yeah like you're sure
you're very fancy today yeah well you
you usually dress like a slob and so I'm
dressed like a slob hoping that you'd be
dressed like a slob
why do you say that I don't just like
you but you've got a nice shirt on and
now I feel like I look like a dick and
you look all nice I feel like you always
were you dig me yeah really but I'd like
I'm trying to match your low level of a
tire that's not really dress that poor
yeah I was just remembering one time you
did we did this episode and you were
wearing your underwear I mean I
according video yeah but you couldn't
get it out of you yeah but I could see
it I bet anchors do that you know on TV
I think they do I think I've seen
something where guy stood up and it was
like denim wearing shorts or something
yeah yeah no shoes no shoes farts they
don't care it's a desk show did the Deaf
cares and we gonna do dates at the top
we already did them babe oh we did yeah
sorry
yeah I like when you get mad at me like
cut stupid no it's a good question right
when I hear you we redid it babe thank
you really you're gonna hit me or guide
me how much do you hate me in my
fantasies how much you hate me when I
fuckin fantasy when I get something
wrong leg cut what does it do to you it
upsets me Anna if I can just have my
core yeah yeah yeah why there's such a
dumb question because it was it was a
silly question as dumb dumb yeah stupid
and then in your head do you are you
like so stupid bitch yours are just my
no that's your internal yeah you always
kind of make up insults
I do I always assume when I upset you
that you're like stupid fucked up and I
never say that and you either that but
what are you saying it has to be some
variant of that like
stupid I was single wish I was on tinder
does it go there no it's not it's not
that it's not that it's just you know I
wonder how much longer so it's like that
yeah like do you fantasize about the
second wife for just being single second
third Oh would you remarry
no no why go through this again no I
want to do this again would you have a
second family that's the craziest part
when people do that yeah I would you
have more babies with another woman I
mean another state so they don't like
run into each other yeah and then when
you're on you're like I'm really know
one of them right do you tell her I
think you tell no one because you're
like I'm going to have no idea right I'm
going to Denver again yeah well you have
a oh yeah you have to open up that
second company in Denver and you're
always in Denver I'm going to every
other weekend maybe you become a truck
driver that's kind of the easiest way to
do it right yeah
until that trucking companies like you
got a new route you got to go every week
to San Francisco and you're like oh then
you start a third family I guess yeah
you got to be real tight with money oh
my gosh two families to support or and
then if you get up to three that's
bananas
yeah that's too hard not was it and
they're always like Daniel you travel
like I know yeah yeah so it goes I know
well let's start the show okay let's do
it man let's go ready yeah and can't go
attention on the water attention in the
water this is the Orange County
Sheriff's Department
be advised State Parks is asking us to
make an announcement to let you know you
a paddle boarding next to approximately
15 great white sharks they're advising
that you exit the water in a calm manner
sure the sharks are as close as the surf
line oh thank you for your cooperation
who is Randy don't bring anyone love
into this no motherfucker
well welcome welcome to your palms house
with Tom Segura
[Music]
so ridiculous you're turning into such
an angry dad what do you know funny like
this morning Ellis was splashing water
outside the sink because he plays in the
sink and then he likes to do this thing
where he splashes outside because then
we get mad and then we pull him out like
it's a game we all play now yeah and he
spilled water like he does every time he
like god damn and Ellis
god damn it would I tell you about the
water scare him I was like oh that's
such a dad mode like you went to full
dad mode on him well yeah I mean he was
spilling a lot of water come on goddamn
it I have a feeling I'm gonna be a lot
of goddammit oh the kids gonna hear that
all the time yeah yeah so dads do though
to show their rage I'm gonna be angry
someone where do you get a lot of
pent-up anger and then it comes out yeah
it's little things like this huh right I
guess it's all like for you but then it
comes out to other thing I figured I
figure like you don't want to we don't
want to confront whatever annoys you in
the moment and then it stores out the
store got the doors up and then you get
mad at the kids filling water early
Christina forgot that we did the dates
alrighty oh so angry yeah yeah um this
is terrifying we saw this clip and I
I've swam in those waters I think I
learned to surf along the waters yeah
and the crazy the Orange County
Sheriff's Department oh my god matter
you're paddleboarding out there now they
fly over first you notice them hovering
or they're hovering if somebody's in
trouble out here and then they go hey
you don't be alarmed they're just coming
on down yeah great white sharks
yeah calmly take yourself to the to the
shore how did that guy even contain his
emotions enough to be that calm the guy
saying yeah I kind of laughed I thought
at one point she's like uh I hear a
little there's a little pitch change
where he said calm handling and
sounds like he's almost laughing because
he knows oh my god look at the fucking
size of that 15 of them dude attention
on the water attention in the water this
is the Orange County Sheriff's
Department made by State Parks is asking
us to make an announcement to let you
know you are paddle boarding next to
approximately 15 great white shark
slowly they're advising that you exit
the water right here in a calm manner
you know these reading errors are as
close as the surf line well thank you
for your cooperation
man if I heard that shit and why was my
honor yeah I have to be paddling fast as
blood well you're not is
heavily-populated up great white sharks
I some of which which on it the surf
line please get out into the water
company parcels are out to make
additional announcements fuck me
how about you guys drop a line down and
pluck that person out of the water but
you're in the fuckin they do that that's
how they rescue people drowning or far
out you they just drop a line down and
then the lifeguard jumps out and gets
you out I know I'd say let's do that
instead of the announcement over and
over well we would all a little more
complicated size of action no I
when I was on road real sided no no I
know I trained I was a Coast Guard I
trained I trained with the Australian
Coast Guard I did a Bondi Beach and they
taught us how to do that that was one of
the missions how you get lowered by the
rope and then you pluck the person out
so what's your theory on why they didn't
do that I don't know laziness you think
they're just being lazy yeah I think
they wanted a cool video to submit to
you to get those hits those views I I
don't know you know that's not true I
know who knows you know it's not true
it's not yeah that'll be terrifying
though oh my god
great whites whites whites right there -
yeah fuck man
look it's not there's a lot of them go
ahead that's there's got to be nothing
fucking scarier I mean I think if I
heard that announcement all like as soon
as he fucking started that announcement
the first moment attention on the water
there we go the water this
the Orange County Sheriff's Department
when bid my State Parks is asking us to
make an announcement to listen who you
are paddleboarding next to approximately
15 green white New York's HR dare
advising that you exit the water in a
calm manner and then just pull the
diarrhea kind of coming out the back of
my shorts no do you think that would
attract the Sharks to or repeal repeal
no fish it there'd be a new it's just a
new tastes new smell them and they don't
fuckin great yeah that's what you eat
it's all ground up in an out burger and
what whatever trash you've been eating
on the road I didn't trash although I
did have horrible meals in Eugenie I
heard that's what I'm saying yeah sickle
cell and I went up to Eugene and back to
Portland Oregon
yeah and Portland shows were really fun
man we could not get a good meal it's so
weird I hate that we went to Eugene we
went I don't want to trash the places
you know because it's like it's they
weren't like egregiously trying to
through an hour's time yeah he just
wasn't good we had we went to a place
for lawns really this is fucking dogshit
what did you order
well he had he had a shrimp cockpit uh
and there was salad shrimp ah ones that
are naughty I would say 1/4 of 1 inch
you know those yams yeah and then order
some oysters for us bookies hey where
did you guys go with that I want to play
a place no it's a nice over there like
it's a good restaurant it was fucking
terrible then we want to I forget
another place after show is alright and
then we breakfast the next morning the
hotels in de Geste it was narrow now
fucking up breakfast is hard it sucks
yeah now we went to Portland and we did
have something good you know you can
only be something good in Portland
Oregon
Portland's amazed for eating there we go
we go so is meat rattle such good food
and meat rattle - yeah really doesn't
this is our first good meal was in
Portland
terrible there's nothing worse than bad
road food because then with the road
food comes the road shit oh so now your
asshole hurts it was hungry you're
miserable tired but but thanks everybody
that came out that's crazy individual
or shows a revolution all so great yeah
it's amazing thank you everybody
jeans there I wanted to point out that
um you and Ryan are both in a special
category now yeah you both no longer
buying regular people shoes no I since I
had a child my back's messed up my feet
messed up I have sciatica and I started
to wear orthopedic shoes yeah now not
all of them look good there's a brand
called vionic but I've been into and
they make really good looking orthopedic
shoes yeah and then this is an unpaid
sponsor me yeah it is yeah the real
thing because if you if you have
sciatica of like spinal misalignments or
whatever I have one leg shorter than the
other it's but now my whole life but for
some reasons if I had a kid my hips got
all messed up and everything so it's
gotten bad here's what oh yeah
sickle-cell worthy I have the same ones
but slip on the fishes a choose the
sandal dead our support seven Oh again
New Balance he said they come in four
colors only yeah it's like these all
maroon yeah I think beige and one other
but he said they completely changed the
way his back again go you have to
because I'll women's shoes are horribly
unsupportive if not damaging to our feet
the ballet flats or so can't even do it
well this is by the way yeah I have
those I have those exact except slip on
from when I was preggers yeah
it's terrible oh my god mr. Hanson's are
my new ones yeah those look more than
you too some people really liked them
and some people fucking hated them I
can't believe how many people everyone's
an asshole are those for bicycling no no
the notes are bicycling they're not are
they for running or a specific sport no
no there's just total like what do they
call you know social shoes like they're
just walk around shoes they're not for
street wear okay yeah but a man they got
a lot of people like like this touch it
it's a terrible them shits is doodoo
someone called these dad shoes these are
like yeah this super exclusive
of undefeated collabo or the Divas no
dad shoes well can I tell you there's a
fine line between cool sneakers and then
too much going on yeah to make them look
supportive and then that's where it goes
into a dad sneaker yeah so I think what
why they're saying that this is just my
theory yeah
is when you got a lot of different hooks
and things injure it when it starts to
look like a hiking shoe a suit or a
bicycle shoes yeah whatever go ahead get
that way loses is cool yeah I still
think they're I think this is a bunch of
nerds on my fucking Instagram yeah does
no style whatsoever I don't know I kind
of agree with I'm sorry I think those
are a little dad support yeah really
yeah I don't know I think yeah I think
there's a bunch of tools I'm going to
put a picture of my shoes my new
orthopedics and we'll see who like who
they like better I'm clearly the shoe
champ you did send it you did send in
those send back those terrible ones
right well because I ordered them and I
got four pairs and I tried them on for
you because look I let's keep it real
you're the one that looks at me all the
times I want to look decent yes
so you okayed two of them and then to
you were like no yeah did I have shit
down to I thought I should I'm sorry you
shut down one pair the other one didn't
they're too big yeah they were a hot
pink slip on sneaks yeah like a strap
like a mary-jane strap on top and you
did not like that look
well what about but you were you not in
wish we had a photo of them so I could
really break it down you can google it
bionic slip-ons hot pink see VI o n I
see Bionic slip on women sneaker pink
hot pink tried Alan okay now they also
make a cool ass lavon's I got a gray
pair like Slade looking little dope and
then I want ya those um yeah those are
that's it see I just don't feel like
they were that bad is so wack these are
like what you know that you know just
reminds me of ha I'm somewhere in Europe
and then some 78 year old American woman
is on was with a tour group uh-huh she's
like I have
been back here in 50 years and he walks
around the corner wearing these I'm like
oh that's nice old lady sneakers you got
on yeah because she's like I didn't have
them I'd just collapse to the ground in
pain is she wearing khaki culottes yeah
yeah no these are terrible I thought
those were cute now try the blue color
do you like the blue ones better is it
not a color thing oh it's not a color
it's the style yeah Mac is fuck old lady
style yeah but I need sneakers that are
have art that have art okay we've got to
keep hunting right now I have I have the
New Balance one they're identical to
what sickle-cell wears I'm not even
joking terrible you should see them when
he had jeans on oh we got to get him
some bionics I know I'm telling you it's
all about that arch support yeah because
my feet will hurt if I just wear regular
flats yeah can't do it yeah forget it
it's crazy it's part of Aging you know I
know so your feet will hurt my feet will
hurt major bud my back sciatica it all
flares up it's really bad yeah it's a
fun of being 40 yeah
so we also went on a mommy's night out a
TM n total mom night we spent the night
in a hotel like we do once a month yo
and we ate a lot of bad food don't tell
our trainer no don't tell her and we
also relax in bed we watched a shitty
movie didn't we watch me stupid yeah was
it started that um what's that great
actor he was on Breaking Bad the young
kid oh yeah I like that I don't know his
name no no Blake some Blake Lively
Lake Lively the guy from Breaking Bad
and it was a cool premise but I just
went to shit so many movies just go to
shit yeah they just shit the fucking bed
and this one did too the premise was
that his girlfriend just disappeared
like they were together for four years
and then one day she disappear so what
happens to her and then he starts
looking for and you're not kind of like
all the answers you get that kind of
thing so you're start you get involved
you get invested yeah
but the reveals are are just stupid
yeah the end was kind of lame super lame
yeah super line I also you know what
disappoint this is not
mean you can say that this is a sexist I
guess but I don't buy her being what
they said she was in other words not
that I don't believe any woman could do
that I don't believe that actress is
that yeah
you understand I'm saying and if she ah
you're saying like she's not it's not
believed he wasn't tough enough in a
weird she wasn't come on she was just
like a cube lon
she wasn't like a tough tough blonde I
mean yeah it's completely unbelievable
no what about a look I've got a lady
doctor do you buy that
it depends yeah where's she from right
what about a lady scientist is that
totally ridiculous - yeah like a not
attractive one sure like a Grey's
Anatomy what's her name the blonde
actress
I don't know Hegel Katherine Heigl again
by scientists that she was a doctor no
course not
no no what should she be 225 to 240 what
large is everything no uh what should
she be occupation wise what Katherine
Heigl that you'd believe that she what
she does for a living in a movie I'm
saying oh I'm drinker yes oh no that's
disgusting real estate real estate yes
yeah secretary secretary yeah that's not
for hot chicks anymore oh that's one
with 50 light a tenant yeah but yeah
Nate agent gate agent at the airport no
what could she be I mean I'm I'm of the
school of thought that she could be a
scientist a doctor or a lawyer detective
okay yeah okay so your theory that
attractive people don't go into
professions either gender really that's
not true we have attractive people that
we professionally deal with don't get us
into trouble now
okay no we don't okay we have really
good looking professionals that we deal
with now come on now okay you know
that's not true I mean I'm not saying
there's not any out there but that's a
most part you know uglier people have to
strive to make a name for themselves
they have to work in life so I feel like
you usually
the uglier looking people let's move on
let's go on to their table but I'm
totally right about that I don't know
now I do know it's not like a it's not
like you don't see supermodels at the
hospital no you don't see many
supermodel doctors that's true
now watch we're going to get a bunch of
emails from people who are like I was a
model and now I'm a scientist yeah the
amateurs send pictures okay right okay I
bet you're a borderline model marginally
attractive or a plus-size model Pig yeah
yeah your big old dirty fucking dicks
hanging down donkey - it's like oh
speaking of movies yeah so we also were
trying to keep the family tradition
going in our our NIDA way of ordering an
adult film right oh well let's just say
it's a tradition that started we didn't
start the fire but it started on us and
the Dominican Republic when we stayed at
a resort that played hardcore
pornography on our television and it was
like wow does everybody get this in
their room no no because we asked it was
just us and we watch a lot of hardcore
stuff that we could be our yeah and then
I got us to kind of getting used to that
now it's hard to go back it's true
it's like eating at 5-star restaurant
and then you know you can't go to
McDonald's every day after that so now
when we stay in a hotel or go into
vacation
we like to order it on TV that D our
place it was around the clock non-stop I
was in a hotel in Europe one so it was
like that - yeah and somewhere where it
was like 24/7 you get hard-core
pornography
yeah and in this place it was obviously
you order a movie right or you can order
like the 4-hour package and all that
stuff for hours and so fine it's a thing
about would be our is that like your kid
could just turn the channel and find
that I wasn't on restricted times you
know was channel 69 right right hi which
is kind of cool because then you can
explain two things your kid at once sure
there's sixty-nining yeah and this is
hardcore porn
but this was a Miss out babies are made
yeah we uh we looked through the titles
that was not one of them yeah no but we
were trying to figure out like wow is
powerful snot jeez yeah I'm trying to
figure out what's the what's the one we
want to watch what's your theme for the
night going to be yeah I mean yet a lot
to choose from there's a lot of milf
stuff is very popular very popular but
we also found that a new genre not new
but a genre yeah become had multiple
films prevalent that was Harry hmm hand
start seeing four or five titles in a
hotel right it's a trend yeah it's
picked up it was like my Harry teen and
my wife's hairy bush their hair oh yeah
yes yeah yes yeah it's interesting on my
theory on the hairy stuff is that that
place probably accommodates what's
popular by the client for the clientele
yeah so either it's like maybe they have
a lot of Asian businessmen who are in a
hairy stuff maybe it's Europeans who
come over and like hairy stuff why those
- why do you categorize those - well I
know that the Asians are very they're
into specific kinky stuff yeah they like
you know there are vending machines that
sell dirty panties in Japan the
schoolgirl thing I know yeah so they
have particular kinks nationally I'm
sure we do - I just don't know them I
don't know like what do we like I think
we're obsessed with mothers milfs know
which is really popular which is just
code for over 30 like it's not it's a
sterile world right it doesn't mean
you're a mom it just means you're over
you know a team yeah it's either teen or
milf it's super weird so I'm gonna go
with Asian even if Asians are because
they are generally hairless or less
hairy than white people so I'm thinking
they that might be the new king I don't
know what do you watch here who's buying
me Harry stuff I see I think it's less
specific to them specifically as much as
it is just that's where the trend is
period across the
really I think so yeah so you're saying
that that's just the genre are all over
the world
I mean maybe not all over the world but
I'm saying that overall I think that
John was probably just popular the
moment sure wow it's exciting new for me
yeah are you following the breast feed
you you crisis got to be big miss oak
reindeer itch yeah you suck meat why
look here look here all for you with
your thirsty I can come on another job
okay would you rather impromptu you who
would you rather feast on this guy's big
nips oh oh you're doing top play with
your new friends it's not sexual you're
just wearing the costumes I think I had
to wear a costume really yeah overnight
I made my eyes water well part of that
would it be a present for you oh yeah I
wouldn't like him talking about it all
the time oh my god and I remember him
big hang like dick yeah like what it
like body dysmorphic nipples yeah
they're not you know yeah he clearly
played with them a lot or stretched him
but he fucked him up yeah so he can make
videos like this what a noble cause to
destroy your nipples so that you can
make videos for other perverts to look
at oh god yeah so okay so we had the
titles there was Harry but then there
was yeah the one that really caught our
attention really caught our attention
I'm really disappointed didn't watch it
though kind of said can I tell the title
sure it was fuck my Triple D slut wife
yeah right I was like this is perfect
Billy I got one right here going next to
me yeah
what I thought you were doing movies
behind my back yeah well you know of
course you know what I really like
that is that it incorporates two genres
there's the big boobs yeah and also the
cuckolding thing of like humiliate me by
fucking my way yeah I'm with Triple D
another popular genre yeah that's a big
one yeah yeah well I just googled that
um that title and I found some other
ones I found I let him fuck my slut wife
please bang my wife Triple D fuck me
my friend fucks my wife and comes in her
what I like about these titles is
there's no mystery there no yes or no
there's no veiling what what's happening
here yeah kind of nice I know what your
pilot wife just nothing man is it maybe
bang my time I might be banging my
Triple D slut white really yeah good F
might be too harsh can I please turn the
air up I'm freezing oh it's fun it's
distracting my legs are freezing my
white wife is used by three black clouds
no no what are you doing man I'm so cold
yo sweatshirt on my I have my I don't
have socks on oh come on man you're ruin
everything you ruin everything
what are you raising it to would you put
it on we have heat lamps in here man
please you seriously ruin this how did I
ruin you just did right now fine you
don't even feel it
oh no I'm gonna lower it if it gets too
hot we'll just turn the air on that's
all I need your balls milk you're so
aggressive today so anyways grasses we
didn't order that film it also brought
me back to the time we went on a cruise
with my parents yeah my whole family
actually and we decided we want to order
a movie then and we did and on this
cruise you could order a film yeah and
it was a softcore film yeah it was so
disappointing that before like you'd pay
to watch softcore so dumb
so after we fast-forwarded through it
and realized what it was
I called guest relations
and the Filipino guy was like huh I said
I ordered this movie and and there's
there's no penetration and he goes bah I
said I wanted hardcore I want to see it
going in and out check with his manager
and he was like ok we were refunding no
we checked it we asked him are there any
hardcore ones I don't want to see
softcore waste of my time and money yeah
so then he he put us on hold and he
asked his manager if there any hardcore
film production and we didn't actually
quit debate
bang bang my Triple D slap egg white I
have such a soft spot for that lady yeah
because you know she's like you know
what we're here to do just go yeah she
was like come on pick my kid up from
school three quit debating god I just do
bro yeah I mean Casa smoking come on
yeah you could tell that she's just like
yeah it's horrible pick up the pace a
little bit
it's horrible you know I back to your
thing about attractive people I was
thinking about it you're right that a
lot of them become like trainers
personal trainers I seem as a it's a
it's an exercise in their own vanity oh
yeah yeah there's a trainer
my friend Mary Lynn showed me a picture
of on Instagram and I was like this
guy's like perfect like you ever see
somebody who's so attractive just
perfect that you're I can't even look at
your it makes me uncomfortable also
Graham's the place to find them by the
way they have found their their place in
this social media world yeah like this
Instagram you just like if you open your
explore page sometimes they're just
beautiful people and you go there and
it's like it's not any one of like any
known field or Talent they're just like
I'm incredibly good-looking yeah and I'm
sharing it with all of you yeah amazing
hold that's there for them do they get
paid do you think I think a follower if
you build up enough followers you
definitely get paid just for being
good-looking well it's like that Cameron
Dallas boy that we watch the Netflix
show about all those boys by the way I
love their Instagram feeds because
they're all really cute and that's all
they do and then they do meet and greets
and they make a ton of money but here's
the best part on Instagram you see what
they're spending their money on oh and
right now it's like here's my new
Lamborghini went along with the doors
that come up or whatever like DeLorean
type here's my this place I'm renting
right now and the Hollywood Hills and
you're like doh you're renting like buy
a house like they're renting these
really expensive houses they're getting
ridiculous cars they're going on
ridiculous vacations I'm like you're
just burning through it if I got that
kind of money at 16 yeah din are you
going to do so stupid you feel like I'm
gonna get this forever you don't think
that would ever slow down no I know what
are they going to do when they turn 30
it's like 30
well how about when they turn 20 I'm
going to go away I know I can be cute
little kids anymore oh my goodness
they're gonna be doing I don't know
stuff like this problem
[Music]
fuck me yes sir and fuck me oh yes sir
yes there's $600 the real is
meet-and-greets you need to make 600,000
in a week is Christ can you imagine how
painful that is
but is such that's also a very daunting
clip because it's like is he liking it
or not sorry
right down the middle yeah there's
moments of both feelings yeah yeah
here's something that's horribly
upsetting yeah uh goddamn it this is
like this pisses me off that this even
exists this is real the desire will need
to move from being able bodies to be
tabled through choice Constance Troy I
got it yeah there's I say never a lot of
fuckin assholes out there yeah if you're
like wait what do they want notice
number want some phone annotation what
either rolling two legs or one or two
arms and a number wants to be paralyzed
and come round they have a very specific
point at which they want the ability to
be power line I mean okay
and here you just beat the fuckin right
and islands I'll do that I'm worship
here's the thing is that we're supposed
to be super tolerant of everybody's
needs and emotional stage but at what
point can we just be like you know what
you're fucking mentally ill yeah okay
you got problems and you need to go see
a shrink because your heads fucked up
yeah you are you're fucking weird
why can't we just call people weird
anymore or abnormal hey guess what your
psychology it's abnormal you're not
normal it was a it's a pry back on
people saying that too much for
everything like in other words people
were told you're not normal
if you're gay right right right feelings
pushback is that anything anything you
want is embraced you want to you want to
amputate your arms to feel special and
different yeah go ahead your fucking
asshole yeah and total asshole no I mean
I really it enrages me that somebody is
going to sign up for that like fuck you
know lucky you are
well if you're going to amputate your
arm then donate it to a vet who just had
his fucking arms blown off by an ie D
and Afghanistan no person is 32 blind
wants to become like your episode of
this guy and Jimmy P go for it good
please so you don't reproduce we need to
move away from pathologize uh-huh
appreciating the very real disrespect
thank you okay no you know what
pretending they're not thinking they are
get over it delay message it way that
they won't let you move oh my dear but
we shouldn't help them now and we
shouldn't feel badly for them no I think
we should go back to reap ethology Seng
young bull you need to call them fucking
weirdos and and abnormal they come into
a room yeah a couple of fucking baseball
bat there you go and give them a real
fucking beating and then afterwards like
you still want to lose Eglin that's what
you should do and see if they feel the
same way yeah yeah you know what I think
the problem is is that we don't
institutionalize people anymore I think
Reagan deinstitutionalized a lot of the
mentally ill in the 80s and since then
the thought of putting somebody in a
mental hospital is considered very taboo
but I think you should I think there are
people who need to be locked up I mean
what does this guy want to do celebrate
them
yeah I'm right hey there's a whole group
of dumb people out there they want to do
some dumb shits themselves and we should
all be there to help the poor talking
about why we have to support every
stupid thing that exists so fuckin some
shit you don't have to support some
stuff is this is wrong
I mean imagine the person listening to
this who was a who went to fight for our
country and had his arms blown off and
sitting and listening to this fucking
exactly
that's what I'm saying like people have
been in accidents or stupid and they're
like yeah it's been a real thrill that
this happened and you want this to
happen yeah fuck you fuck you and your
stupid arm you're dead have you been
very carefully considered options and
you present a number wrong station the
only way forward
yeah all I'm hearing though is that they
want to do it he hasn't said that like
and then they did it do you realize that
good doctor is going to voluntarily no I
want them to do it in their fucking
backyards like I want to hear the story
of that you know what that's a great
idea is if you gotta do it you gotta do
it yeah I get like a wooden yeah what is
that just like a cut-off tree a stomp in
the backyard into an axe and if you can
do it it's yours you get to do it no I
want to make youtube videos though they
come on yeah yeah yeah where you got to
have to have a horrible or hilarious
segment see if I saw hilarious as far as
I'm concerned for these assholes
most people know these feelings kept a
just a feeling so thank you and they
don't go away
can we just leave the society needs to
appreciate okay but however strange
insane yeah yeah it isn't beyond the
pale to allow people to align the whole
T which are they feeling no can I say
also the other problem with today's
society is that just because you feel
something doesn't mean you have a
legitimate right to act on every fucking
impulse I know healing is a lot of
feeling out there yeah yeah it's like
you feel really feeling I feel a lot of
ways to I didn't tell you just fucking
sit on this feeling right are you
sublimate those feelings through
healthier outlet right so maybe okay I
want to be an amputee well maybe how
about not coming arm up but maybe I do
artwork
about amputees or I work with people
with it you know why don't you add an
app for a jujitsu school see if they'll
break your fucking arm like just a bad
at it and then it'll happen that's for
the best guy every week and just be like
armbar me bro
see if you can just keep cracking us
yeah maybe that'll so to go to a few
Klan rallies yeah go to the Klan rally
well I'm to say like an LA and get the
shit beat natty or just wear like a
trump shirt in LA in LA you know what I
mean do something stupid okay yes
speaking of raging it is horrible or
hilarious
this is one that came in poof I don't
know if I could even handle this one
[Music]
what just happened what just happened
what was that what was that what was
that what is that is that what I'm not
looking I'm not a mout his nut King
laughs when I came out oh my god oh my
god oh my god I don't know about it like
that I can't look at this is my good one
smiler I don't know what happened oh no
oh that's it he tied a rope to his balls
and then jumped I don't know what is
that what it was I don't know what he
did everything's I'm upset I don't like
it oh my god oh my god guys oh my god do
did not came out do this again oh my God
look at that guy he's like I'm leaving
dude that's not cool
we have an incident at the Heritage Park
in Raleigh Virginia my friend Kiki tied
a rope he tied a rope to himself and
they took off running off a tree it was
just like uh he was just like pulling
around and like a bunch of guys were
around we're just goofing off and you
know he ended up ripping his like his
testicle yeah okay well that's a
horrible one I'm vulnerable one okay
let's take this ticket breather take
fall so well okay that was a full
fucking
stoppage you actually change clothes you
were so traumatized blue band is here
he's adjusting the lighting because
we're having a guest come in soon that's
the thing that we wanted to announce
that we're actually having a guest in
studio for the first time in well first
time here and also the first time in I
don't know it's got to be like two years
or something yeah because once we move
from the from Redondo to house and then
we were recording the show next to our
sons nursery so we didn't really want to
have guests coming in and out of our
baby's room essentially so it's been a
while it's been a while but here we are
and we're you know we're set up for a
guest but listen turns out that guy
because I didn't want to look again yeah
he tied a rope to his ball bag yes
stupid jumped with the other end tied to
a tree so stupid what do you think I got
me happened yeah yeah yeah I thought I
saw the Rope as I do he did not just
well the verdict is in horrible or
hilarious it was fucking horrible
horrible wait so you didn't even find
that I thought it was funny in the
beginning because I was like that's just
a dumb kid and then now what what made
it not funny for you dude any ball
related traumas not funny to me I can't
I can't do it just because it's a guy
guy hurting his nuts I can't do it yeah
you you have empathy is that what you're
saying in those situations yes you're
able to put yourself in somebody else's
shoes yes and feel that pain can I tie a
rope around your balls no just for fun
no you're not into that it's a little
tug tug tug traumatic yeah yeah the hold
on can I can I bring up another topic
before we move along sure I really want
to get this in it's super important the
other day you were calling me from
horrigan and you run I was on the phone
here at home you were on the phone and
horrigan and I was talking and I had to
fess up and tell you the truth that I
was actually sitting on the toilet
making yeah oh I'm sorry but I gotta go
I'm taking a shit and I realized I
couldn't shit with you on the phone it
didn't feel honest yeah and then use it
I said you're never going to believe
this
I'm browning too they were both browning
at the same time it's synergy right yeah
yeah and I hit the mute button so that
you didn't hear right like when you
would start talking I would hit him you
and then push really yeah that was my
problem with Browning with you is that I
would have I was afraid you were going
to hear my sounds too but that was
really thoughtful of me you agreed on
that yeah I was really nice and I wish I
had thought of that strategy of muting I
didn't even think of it it was crazy to
me because I thought I'd snuck in there
why did he did I did you coat it and
then you're like I gotta tell you I'm
Brown I was like huh like you either you
are so excited you know you seldom show
emotion or excitement yeah I mean even
when I told you I was pregnant you're
like stop it
yeah somebody send us email speaking of
Brown is it gross to Brown at a strip
club now I need the segura not to settle
right the situation happened I believe
only top dog and bun so me and my dad
can provide a balanced perspective on
this on Friday my best friend and I went
to a sleazy strip club to enjoy adult
entertainment my friend Dan had a couple
beers and he said where is the pisser in
this joint emotion to the hallway next
to the DJ booth I turned my attention
back to the ladies grinding and they're
removing their clothes 25 minutes later
Dan came out of the bathroom
apparently Dan decided to take a shit in
the bathroom at strip club the savage
animal will shit anywhere I feel like
shitting in a stripper is never allowed
this is the most foul and horrid place
to relieve oneself here's the question
is it reasonable to make brown I think
it's reasonable I think so and here's
why strip clubs are disgusting places to
begin with yeah because that sounds like
that's his logic for why not to do it
and I think that's that's odd I think if
we were able shit out at night at bars
and stuff though I think that's not
you're at a bar you take a shit that's
different yeah it's weird that you got a
shit at that hour you know I had a
friend that every time we go
nightclubbing and high school in college
the minute we get to the club she'd have
to shit really
every time that nerves though was a
nurse and so she would be like awesome
if I have to go fucking shit at this
club I mean it
uncomfortable yeah to shit at a
nightclub yeah people are waiting in
line I think anywhere where there's a
long line of people and it's not really
now I do get by the way I guess he's
saying you know there's so many gross
dudes and they don't obviously don't
care for the facilities but I mean most
bathrooms are pretty gross as I'm saying
at the strip club like guys are
obviously piston and probably jerking
off all over those sharing rooms but I
mean you know I'm sure you have to shit
yeah these guys go take a dump but I
think anywhere well here's an ideal
place to shit when there's lots of
stalls like a you know a Dodger game is
fine yeah Airport ideal for shitting
because there's a lot of traffic in and
now it's quick people make quick trips
you know yeah I got a message you as as
395 audio trouble
there's trouble in 395 really you see
this there's an audio problem the
episode when Tom plays an audio clip of
Sarah burns voicemail there's a constant
howling in my ear I know a lot of
barking deer moving stupid actually
every voice member 5friends I'll take a
packet on let me know this issue can be
resolved thanks Chris Wow harab ah now I
know what do you mean I know it means
speaking of dogs
Bitsey is in love with blue band yeah I
don't know what you eat before you come
over here but this dog can't stop
licking him yeah hey Jew flavor she
loves Wow two flavors
what are you eating gefilte fish your
hands covered and lox before you come
over oh and she loved the associates
loves it just for a reference uh here
you see here is is not working what is
this not working
can I talk about my experiment when
you're looking for that then did you
line it so our son it turns out is
lactose intolerant and you and I did
that 23andme genetic testing a while
back and it revealed that I was lactose
intolerance true which really makes
sense because I fucking hate milk and
every time I would have ice cream my
stomach would just be
rekt i would get gas bubbles like really
painful yeah I can eat cheese pretty
much is fine but milk liquid it destroys
me so my son has it now we stopped
feeding him regular milk he drinks
lactose free milk and I thought I'd go
yeah he's totally fine now
and I thought to myself what if I just
tried drinking some milk and just to see
if my really yeah the thing that I know
that's true is really right sometimes
you have to verify it yeah
and so I drank some milk and sure enough
I shit like three times after and it was
really painful and so guess what I'm
lactose intolerant
but just for milk yeah and you've
already knew this and I knew this but I
wanted to retest the theory here is just
to be clear I pulled up burns voicemail
stop it and then the scene it's so
stupid she's gorgeous
I know here's Mary Lynn yeah I can see
what he meant Mary Lynn Rajskub also
star of 24 your friend Sean a girl
fantastically good-looking
Sean if I was their last name and then
yeah it was just very good-looking too
all my friends are very attractive and
there you are cotton yeah I don't know
what they I mean it sounds like that was
the issue but I mean it's I like it
sweet you're saying my friends are the
dog pound what what kind of lookers do
you think you have in your bunch who's
in your corner burner bugs all right
hahahaha bad it's working comedian out
there yeah my god who's your hi friend
you're like Shamu Ben no Jew
motherfucker yo guru ban yeah come on
who else do you have now your friends
are lovely this is you know we know your
friends are dogs okay okay oh man that
was fun Kattan your your where to do
that guy yeah oh yeah yeah no one knows
done it they're all they're all
unattractive your friends are lovely
they are they aren't lovely yeah they're
good-looking one of them would you marry
they're all marriage material they are
yeah yeah
they will been married or are married
yeah they're all marriage material okay
now I would output in all of them stop
it what I didn't say put it in I said
marry now I would I was finishing all of
them stop it what the problem with my
friends they all got hungry tips and you
like floppers oh no they anger doesn't
matter really no of course not I thought
you were into big flops I liked his
period I don't care what size they are
yeah yeah but you like I'm hanging mushy
purple there or they can be hungry and
starving doesn't matter I don't care
put them in put him put them everywhere
leave them out I like him do you like
blondes that but still I mean none of
them are blind hey if she is the grass
on the field snow bed sit down huh sit
down what's that is because you can it's
all pink on the inside
God does so here's a dad boner this
one's pretty fucking great this dad
boner decides to go fishing with a drone
it was like his own little experiment
today we're going to doing something
that's another internet first and
totally outrageous we're gonna go
fishing lousy yeah we're not using worms
and we're not a little cause we're on
Lake Champlain and we are going to be
trolling with a jitterbug whoo
let's see how this goes adjudicator bye
then the drone low heritage like that
it's online
oh my gosh did you just see the fish
jump I got a fish oh my gosh oh my god
you get oh my gosh
[Applause]
holy crab apples clever how about all
the ways he that's just I'm oh my gosh
Marian oh my god
Marian okay sis oh my gosh
just crazy at that drone cocktails
alright ma'am I wish you'd get this
excited for me like when you yell for me
to come I am I love that look I want I
thought what the drone it's a huge
freaking bat nice tell me the numbers on
my GoPro rolling more get that size of
this get your camera crews quickly go
Val Val you got to hurry up my god put
the Marian's like I am sorry is I mean
shoot sideways
quick quick quick turn the site where
the phone sideways Marion's got a
newborn in her arm two other little ones
and this assholes excited about his fish
she I know she's like anything is
important that you're doing she's like
could you justify can help me with his
babies right now Miriam yeah he stoked
about oh my gosh yeah I'd be so mad at
him I like his dad boner style I did yes
pretty good
I do wish you crabapples credible I wish
you would get excited about anything
like that I do get excited about what
though different things nothing in life
is that exciting nothing no come on
I've never seen you get that geek done
anything that's not true never not
excitement excitements not your thing
like personality chance get excited
about god dammit you're just not not
very excitable or fun or I'm pretty
excitable no never
you can't think of one time you never
like jump up and down like oh yeah it's
so rad did it it yeah
watching sports sometimes like you do
yeah okay I'll take that back
football football really you like that
it's exciting order you see me jump and
scream class you know motherfucker yeah
no angry like anger exciting but
sometimes I get really excited you do
yeah at that football there you go
that's a good one
come on don't be a non-binary I want to
amputate one of my arms that's a fucking
assholes man you've got to respect
people Tom there no you don't everybody
has a right to have their feelings
everyone has right to act on their
irrational feelings no the other day
you're in the kitchen and you pulled
your legs up you're in your boxer shorts
you pulled your legs up to your ears and
then you farted at me yeah and I feel
like this might be a turning point for
us and what sway just like in the way of
like is this it like are we are we
brother and sister now like what if you
like you even think of me as a woman
yeah I do of course uh-huh like somebody
that you have sex with or you know that
you see me as like an opposite sex
person yeah you totally are mm-hmm yeah
I totally see you as that until whatever
we recording twelve years ago like we
just started dating would you pull your
legs up and forgot me at the table then
or actually twelve years in the game and
you feel like that's in the game we're
in the game I mean I actually have I
recorded your response when I farted
there yeah I hit it on my phone here you
are I'm a big dog I like that there I am
I'm a breath sounds wave yeah very
Brussels Bert so I'm a small dog yeah
little Brussels feelings you sure yeah
yeah that's me
so that's how I would barger you I don't
think we're over the line you think
across those yeah I think I think we may
have overstepped seriously we may have
entered into territory like officially
in it for life and double the double leg
back pool yeah in their underwear
yeah I thought those that may have may
have put us into weird territory we
should get the house phone smart idea so
no when can you run in there do you mind
it's on the counter
do you think that that may have may have
affected us I feel like I can't unsee it
that's the problem like there's a reason
you and I don't shit in front of each
other yeah because I feel like that
would but that would put us in a
territory like no going back we're
brother and sister now yeah I agree we
don't do that we shouldn't shit in
finish up I mean I don't know if this
has been the line crossing somebody sent
in this evidence that you you are the
fart champ says I am let's see though
let's see what it says I like those dog
works I love dogs evidence that Tina I
am is the fart champ 2013 episode 145 13
I'm with you and you have this horrible
gas problem you just let them rip all
day and I'm like I love her what am I
supposed to do and then you say you
fought a lot more than me I think and I
say no and you say who do you think
farts more and I said you so it's kind
of it's weird in this instance we're
actually role you're declaring declining
that you are I'm insisting that you it
was 2013 team yeah Wow my things have
changed since then
yeah so you you insisted that I was a
fart champion this person says that huh
in episodes 1 2 3 94 yeah there is clear
irrefutable evidence episode 1 that Tom
Segura is the personality champ- yeah
based on from how this ours is more
charming now we're likeable overall has
a better personality wrong Dylan you
haven't many people I meet when I do my
shows that come up to me and they're
like you're the personality champ you're
the best and then I just get tweets all
day long it's like I can't look at my
Twitter feed I don't know how much
personality I have I don't think so I'm
what you do and you have just uh global
happiness yeah you just let them rip all
day oh yeah me and I'm like I love her
Who am I supposed to do there you go
you fart a lot more than me I think know
anything farts more yeah bullshit you
no way you let out a couple monster ones
last night Android this morning this
morning well we ate a lot of prosciutto
and cheese last night for dinner yeah
you and you are insisting that I was
right and you were saying that you
weren't you're saying if you want know
what sometimes we're not always ready
for greatness yeah it's like you you
become great over time you're not always
ready to accept the title so that's what
this is all about hi I'm Kay this
podcast is about discovering oneself
yeah I'm discovering and you're kind of
at that it's the farts of that deep bro
like we're that deep bro is for yourself
for farts yeah discovering yeah
it's a it's pretty pretty wild that that
we've gotten to this point where you're
really finding out who's who and what's
what you know yeah being my Triple D
slut wife whoa Lubin doesn't know about
that Alan mm-hmm
you'll hear it that's where we kept
saying that title over and over to
ourselves over and over stupid bang my
Triple D slut wife bring them cookie
slut wife yeah that's what it sounds
like yeah bang my Triple D slut wife
yeah yeah yeah yeah bang my Triple D
slut life so any moment we should be
joined by somebody it's gonna be I think
we should leave it as a surprise yeah
until he gets here just to be sure at
8:00 yeah of course and it's not what
you expect it's not a comic now an
entertainer but it is a field that is of
great interest to both it means to both
of us well I'm more of an aficionado I
don't think so as usual you're ruining a
great moment but I think you guys will
probably find this as interesting okay
am i rolling those are all signs of
divorce
what about them contempt for your spouse
that's the predictor of divorce and I
rolling is a huge predictor
and both in this family but what about
it you constantly have contempt and I
want you for you I don't constantly have
contempt oh yeah no I know no hard water
comes from where is he
she's here I have come all over my face
somebody tweeted a was it Sean Spicer to
see if he had heard about the comb
strike one of the White House had
commented yeah what this administration
think of the common strike is going on
the what ah for and far in come strike
now I masturbated to everybody in my
family it's so not doing nuts she was so
fucking crazy I can't even imagine okay
so our fucking stupid dogs ran away last
week I don't relive that arrow I was
terrifying it was terrible
so I was in here recording that's deep
bro and I was dinnertime yeah so I open
that I usually keep them in here to
record and then I let them into the
house for dinner time thinking that you
know everybody would be there and I
should have checked to make sure that
the the kitty door was shut we had like
a childproof fence
yeah and I for some reason I looked and
I was like oh that's fine I didn't even
like double check I'm come back in here
to record you come in here like is it
are the dogs in here and the dogs in
here and like no when I didn't say are
the dogs in here I said it's beef and
feast
I had a bit fuck so what happened was I
was upstairs I was on my computer the
phone rings there's somebody outside and
he goes is your dog bitsy oh my god
like yeah we got a have her outside so I
run outside he just stand this dude who
I would not have guessed would be the
type of guy to do this that he did not
look like Oh kind of homeless no he just
looked kind of I don't know just kinda
ready yeah you've heard like a perv or
something yeah yeah so I take bitsy in
and then I'm in by the way on I go
downstairs the front doors open
the front door to our house is open
tetanus
and then I grabbed her I'm terrified and
I'm looking I thought it peace with you
and then when he isn't like a hook shit
and we just go outside and we start
looking for them or looking for vehicles
pizzas back here man we drove all over
this neighborhood I was yelling out the
window absolutely wrong oh my god my
favorite by the way is when we we found
there was one guy and I was like have
you seen a dog a small blonde dog and he
goes yeah no no I haven't seen it
because you should find it before the
Sun Goes Down all those coyotes come out
and I go thanks dude yeah I hope thank
you I was like of course we're gonna
we're going to stop looking for him like
my guess the sun's down we're going to
stop looking for the dog that we've
loved for the last six years
this is asshole of course we're going to
keep due to anyway we finally did a
phone call actually we saw the woman
walking away from our house because he
left me a voicemail it didn't come
through yeah one of the neighbors found
fifo in her yard three houses down we're
houses down and got attacked there we
had we mean we walked Jesus to that area
too but he was you know he's only what
he watches off the ground
yes such as scary though it was really
scary
I was the whole time I kept thinking I
won't be able to sleep tonight if we
don't find fifo I would I would just be
beside myself with grief yeah it was my
firstborn son I know you know how many
hours in labor I spent with that guy
anyways I bought a jeep dog GPS for both
of them they're both chipped but that
you know that microchip shit doesn't
work unless somebody turns them into a
vet or turns them into the shelter yeah
so the chip is not GPS not the same
thing yeah and so I got them GPS and I'm
charging them now and then you put it on
the collar and you can see it on your
cell phone where they are Kenwood and
there's an electric fence thing so that
if they go out out of bounds it'll
notify you we got this email from a
listener ayodhya hopes to shed some
light on this dick forwarding phenomenon
so we can all know thank you what's
going on here I was glassing over your
recent podcasts and I thought this could
be a fantastic learning experience for
all involved Crohn's is a chronic
inflammatory condition with that
inflammation something called fistula is
conformed fistula is basically a little
tube that connects two hollow organs
these can form between your bowel and
blood vessels your skin and even yes
your bladder the last sort of fistula
form is called an enter o vesicular
fistula air and water waste products can
travel from the bow into the bladder
this causes an amazing dick farting
phenomena that we have grown to love
today I'm actually graduating from
medical school in a week I know what I'm
saying
you know what I'm saying put some respec
on my left on my name I love you signed
the dick farting expert really go right
here it's a big part I didn't take part
do the dick farts yeah do the dick farts
smell like farts that you know no one
touched on that no one touched on that I
mean it's air so it could sink well he
says it comes from the bowel good so so
I'm assuming that those dick farts smell
like real farts man this dude was
pissing in his parts we're coming out of
his dick okay would you rather I think
this our guest is going to know what the
topics are before he gets here we go
China would you rather tie a string
around your balls and jump off
nope of a bus bench or have dick farts
for the rest of your life honored Towson
take far today
I really just every time I take it out
just parts a song okay would you rather
dick farts for the rest of your life
yep or one drink from that guy's nipples
uh and you have to be like super thirsty
oh he's like a a softie and you're like
I'm so sorry Todd um I'm so thirsty
daddy that's what you have to say daddy
give me the milk I'm so thirsty
god dammit I don't know where he is oh
he's here
hey German are you thirsty you have a
gym I all the bread see you and he'll be
sick never wash wow you suck read why I
think okay I think I would take one of
those over a lifetime of dick farts yeah
yeah
dick farts it would be a really bad no
to do this this would be really bad
he doesn't have milk in his breast
horrible fuckin vomit going on now do
men have milk ducts I think they do I
think you could can you lactate man I
wonder can men listen maybe I don't know
our nipples are different some I don't
know we have milk that's so gross it's
so disgusting
medical doctor guy can men lactate can
men produce milk I know that they must
have similar equipment look in utero
that's why men have stop it with the
fucking bark oh yeah you know I don't
like it
ha ha ha don't laugh Louie a legitimate
phobia I have I fucking hate it yeah Oh
si yeah it's real it's a fucking a real
mental problem I have I see a fucking
shrink for it you know goddamn it and so
it is here for me I love doing that to
you I know you do that's what that's
what happens on this ok no contempt No
so let's uh let's break and hopefully in
a few moments few minutes we'll return
with a guest that we're very excited
about show me how the dick farts smell
ok we'll be right back alright so we're
back and you don't know that before you
got here this show add a lot of
different topics most of them were
between our n c---seventeen and xxx and
now it's a total change of pace and
we're very happy to welcome by the way
you are our first guest and not
exaggerating here
couple years oh my gosh we used to have
guests all the time did it
I said now if you own it we have the
foremost water someone a in the United
States and actually in the world yeah
even the both know sometimes scary show
me need to get closer that alright
sometimes it's scary for me that I'm
that famous already and as you are it's
Martin Rees correct yeah
three head actually it's like Porsche
Porsche O'Reilly reset does it annoy you
how many people say Porsche wrong they
should say Porsche right I'm braced you
Brennan yeah we live with the snow that
I want to give people yeah the
background to this so what happened was
I actually saw a different one of your
competitors water so lonely a on CNN
there's a piece on him and he was in
Asia Shanghai away meets him in June who
is this guy do you like him do you hate
him no we don't know you I love
everybody who drinks water well make me
like me so not town I don't like that by
the way that's all I saw I'm wearing a
water champ at for those of you
listening right I saw this piece and I
thought oh this is fascinating then I
saw it's in sharing hi and I go well I
guess that'll never happen
then I'm on Instagram and I see this
sixty second piece on you and I'm
watching them like I'll cool another
water swimming it and then I see in LA
immediately I go to your website and
it's Martin - Reese calm and I email
about class you do like privates or a
group class and you hit me back and you
said like you're the water champ how bad
you're not gather it's actually accurate
Martin that is actually happened that
you you have no idea not right back to
you and say you're the water that's
exactly what he said I'll show you the
email just now now here's the thing just
to get people like most people know the
word sommelier and that that always is
you know high-end restaurant they have a
sommelier to tell you about wines and
their origin and how do you come about
becoming a water someone yay so I have
to say it started when I was a child so
on vacation time with my parents I
tasted the different tip waters
around the world when I was on vacation
and my parents always thought like hey
what's wrong with our son what is like
coming to the tap when we end in your
city or something it's like what's
what's up with him and for me it was
like he was like dude what do you think
about the taste of the tap water and
she's like what it's like what what's up
it's like no and for me as a child about
fascinating that everybody said yeah a
tap water and I felt like but there are
so many differences in tap water even
isn't it funny though that this is
something that basically we all I feel
like everybody senses that but you acted
on it in other words we all tried tap
waters as a kid especially and you're
like that but I feel like you're the one
who was talking about it I think the
thing is with kids and I see it right
now my water tasting classes as well
kids love that the course kids taste
pets are still like super fresh they are
not like completely ruined already
because they didn't have too much spicy
food or drink a lot or something like
this for grass so they can really detect
a lot of stuff weight water so you say
that that can actually dull your palate
is having spicy foods or drinking
recording you get accounting so many
different like taste profiles and water
is very subtle in taste when I'm talking
about wine were like different colors
different grades different vintages
different barrel fermentations by water
it's hopefully all comes from nature
and it's all about the mental content so
as a child I realized what has taste and
then in 2005 from worked in a restaurant
in Germany at the restaurant first floor
and customer came up to me and said hey
Martin do you have so many different
wines but you're just having one brand
of water and I don't like this
particular brand do you have something
else for me and I was like looking at
him and I thought like to know what he's
up CT right and the restaurant business
all about options you have different
liquors you have different beers on tap
you have different wines on the menu but
when it comes to water the Sun will ask
you sparkling little tap right what are
you right Martling or bottled never cap
yeah so I thought hey gotta change it
and I wanted to give options to my
guests so I created a Waterman in 2005
so a lot of people always thing like Oh
only in LA there's of water sommelier
yeah actually I'm doing this things over
ten years now so now this is so cool man
and like all our water competitions
aside we are big fans of
like water in general like we we always
start because you know we we were both
drinking water and and had to stand her
back and forth about like who drinks
more but the truth is I do love trying
out different waters and I feel like I
don't know I can't speak for the rest of
the world but it's always a thing here
in the United States that that argument
about you know if you go and you and you
buy this water it's just that's just a
someone took their their their hose in
the back and filled this thing up right
and and you can get how many comments I
had on my social media pages of all this
come on Martin you just have a big hole
somewhere in your backyard and you're
putting all the different different
water shapes and then you're putting all
this water and they think yeah right but
there really is serious differences I
mean I think the inexperienced person
knows that that you know different
waters taste differently but in its
easiest form to explain the difference
really comes down to mineral content
right so it measures by TDS total
dissolved funds
okay one question though because I grew
up in LA and never drank the tap wire I
mean I'm convinced it's just poison
running through and so it's also like
what do you buy as what does the average
person buy to have in their home so
that's another thing I would ask you
because we did Sparkletts for a while
and that was fine but now we have a
water filtration system built into our
house and that's I don't know is it
better so that - I would like to know
from you so the thing is when it comes
to modern I think the biggest important
thing is that people need to understand
where their water is coming from and it
is kind of sad that here in America a
lot of purified water companies are like
the new hit thing and everybody thinks
water should be pure I'm always saying
water should not be pure because when
it's completely pure you don't want to
drink it because your body needs
minerals all the time like magnesium
calcium potassium silicon all these
different minerals what your body cannot
produce by myself so your body needs
constantly minerals that's reason you're
hungry yes the reason you're thirsty
because your body wants minerals so to
have a water kind of like say a tap
water fill that everything out of there
and then it's like super pure water pure
with zero TDS it's actually extremely
harmful for your body
you have no minerals no middle so your
body drinks that mother nature does know
the concept of completely pure water it
doesn't exist in mother nature right so
you're drinking that water the body
things like what the hell is that it's
like I don't even know what this element
is know what I just drunk I need to put
minerals in it to process it to get rid
of it so you're actually dehydrating by
drinking I knew it I knew it can I tell
you because when I did drink tap water
like on the emergency days when we run
out of Sparkletts I swear I would feel
thirsty or after drinking tap water it
never got there funds rate of water but
I don't want to really remind no yeah
Ellie tap water has actually way more
minerals then I need to refine water
companies really so when you want to
stick to a mineral content drink le tip
what so I think even when I would choose
a bottle of like a purified water and
you can see it on the label purified
water here what I brought it's all
spring waters and that's the only thing
I always promote you have waters I've
never never heard of this is what I'm so
excited about I mean there's definitely
I would say amongst I will call us the
regular civilians who are not in your
your league of knowledge everybody kind
of kind of thinks that Fiji is the you
know between Evian and feeds you they're
like those are that's high-end water
usually you pay more for those two in a
convenience store you know 7-eleven and
I in my own palate I do feel like I
taste Fiji as different than other
bottled waters that are around in other
words the M the whatever yellow spray I
forget there's a Florida Springs one and
there's a dis on E
which I'm a dog shed I don't like
spending a terrible on his purified it's
purified my job when you're in this
resourced water building everything out
of their bedding makes some very small
amount of minerals like that amount yes
and I'm selling it fire price is in my
opinion the biggest game of plunder is
Dasani yes in general purified water
company yeah
well that's for me something what I what
drives me crazy and I came to the state
in 2011 and I wanted to create a water
menu right away and it was so hard to
find real spring waters in America
yeah because mostly here the waters are
purified waters and it seems that
hey they are all bind big companies and
the big companies wants to make money
it's coca-cola Danone Nana and Pepsi are
the four biggest water producers in the
world and they all want to make money
with us yeah so therefore it's easier to
use just tap water filtering everything
out of there adding back some minerals
just for taste profile that's like the
waters kind of okay and sending it for a
price yeah therefore I'm sticking always
to spring water and this is what I
always recommend when you go into a
grocery store just check the labels look
for spring glacier or natural source
mineral water and do not buy purified
water don't buy our water okay so you're
essentially doing harm to yourself with
I don't want to say huh but but yeah you
harm yourself definitely buy distilled
water when you bind the MEAC gallons or
my mother you buy that shinra salt water
it's created for like all the batteries
it's for your iron it's not for
consumption right and in Germany they're
big labels on these bottles what you can
buy us one the grocery store do not
drink not for human consumption rely on
America they're like yeah whatever
distilled water that's so good so pure
so marketing plays a big role and Gerald
water companies and I see still people
at the gym with a gallon of distilled
water taking that down and then they're
wondering why they're suddenly like
feeling not really good and you either
always have headaches India dehydrated
oh yeah yeah that's what I drank during
that water cut when I was doing a weight
loss contest you're trying to cut water
in the last few days fighters they told
me that the way you do it is you drink
distilled water to flush your closet.if
lushing every exactly so over a longer
time oh yeah World Health Organization
isn't saying it can be very harmful for
uses for a long time what about Avion is
that a good one I feel like it takes to
me it just tastes so pure and good so
that ones are good and that's so funny
if y'all had a has a loss and hate
relationship to guests it's so funny
some people think I love Evo some people
think I hate Avion and that is the
reason why I have a water menu and the
restaurant it's so actually so simple
when you think about it is actually a
very simple concept can we tell the
people what restaurant patina Restaurant
at the world is to consider and that is
downtown Los Angeles Los Angeles I went
to interview for a job there like 10
plus years ago
yeah my sister used to work for the
patina group that is from and so she set
me up and I went in for an interview and
I didn't get job was it a big job
channel what was it no no like she like
set me up for a forget if it was hosting
for I don't know sometimes I had zero
restaurant experience but I went in and
like I had on a suit funny kind of try -
I should say I love people who have
viewer experience yeah could then I can
actually fold them yeah yeah that's way
better for me I like people who sing
during what Martin I never worked in the
Reston before but I really are eager to
do it and I'm a husband guy that's to me
thousand times better than people coming
to me and saying like yeah I'm worked in
all this fancy places and I know way
more than you right that's true yeah
right oh this will be trouble already
that's true I applied to work at Lowry
steakhouse downtown but then I failed
the drug test cuz I smoked pot the night
before you did the night before she's
starring not smart to relax for the day
[Laughter]
no I'm excited to jump in and try some
waters I another thing we did because we
were talking about this even before you
got it I definitely do this I have a
glass of our filtered system water can I
give you a temper man put too much in it
but I went I just want to see what a
really interesting case never the first
the first thing what I'm doing and this
is already when people seem like what
the hell is Martin doing why is he
looking at a glass of water yeah
and I can already see something like if
there's any mineral content if I can see
something on the TDS levels but there's
like it looks pretty pure to me in this
way there are some the residues right
here but this might be the glass of
Polish turmeric so let's see
smelling there's no chlorine smell so
that's only a good sign because you're
filtration systems obviously in a good
shape because sometimes the problem with
filtration system is as well that people
buying themselves a flotation system
yeah I never think about maybe changing
the soldiers oh I'm on top of it because
it has a light that tells me when we're
good and it turns yellow i buy the phone
um a lot of creatures they are
filtration system in their fridges yeah
and they think like oh I got my great
water from the fridge and they are like
putting this for many many years on
average never change their filter what
that means this will just bucked up one
at one point with all this stuff what
you don't wanna have in your water and
then it's actually harmful so the
children's so filled up that is actually
poisoned the water what's going on yeah
please guys when your filtration system
at home change your your next role to
change your filters all the time sure
cheers Cheers cheers Cheers
come here so the middle Clinton is very
low you can play this right away
um it's a it's a plan what I think to
drink this stuff but the mineral content
is low and management not resume normal
this is Tory know that I think if I have
a filtration system at home as well so
don't worry about it I'm using it like
for showering for cooking for all this
kind of stuff yeah but when it comes to
adjust regular drinking on a daily basis
I'm sticking to bottled water because I
wanna have I want to have a little
variety as well and all of these that
we're looking at here these all are
different to the pallet every single one
of these oh yeah definitely and
price-wise like when we talk about for
instance wines right wines
people who don't buy wines a lot they
just go that's really expensive it must
be amazing and don't realize that a lot
of the times what the price is indicated
above is the exclusivity of it in other
words they make less of these therefore
the price is much higher exactly the
same with water so this is the more
expensive ones are just less like
mass-produced yeah for example I brought
several waters yen is skilled it's a
good example for wine is skilled is way
more expensive than maybe an Evo what
you can buy at the grocery store I love
great vouchers but is skilled it
produces a million bottles per year this
is in the industry like nothing
Pellegrini would laugh about that number
and they're pumping out a million
bottles per week okay so for them it's
just like what do they want it's skilled
it's a very small spring has been
discovered by a retirement couple in
2003 because they wanted to build a
smaller vacation house in Denmark in a
national reservoir and the Danish
government was saying yeah you can build
your house there but you cannot bring a
water pipeline through our national
reservoir and they thought like okay
back to the nature is nice but like the
waters a little bit too much for us
but yeah nature so they found a spring
send it over to a lab and the lab said
like wait a minute what's up with you
order there's something very unique
about it and they thought like oh shit
maybe it's not good the water or
something when the lab is doing this
whole fuss about it they found the most
unique water ever been found and
offering is super super small and
therefore I've been to the spring for
six years ago it's like the spring house
is the size of this building here it's
like super small and when you think
about this and like you see in these two
people they are smiling at you and like
yeah we found this cool water and we've
we wanted to share it with the world and
now they're bonding is skilled means
actually I spring under the English
language I love this kind of stories
yeah exactly
and every water has a little story to it
and I think this is really cool to
discover and then yeah sure you're
paying like I think you can find it at
Arawa now for three or four dollars a
little bit more expensive it's cool it's
a nice story and this is nothing what I
was doing on a daily basis because hey I
need to watch my money as well like
everybody else
yeah so therefore I have big gallons of
arrowheads at my places but when I'm
drinking on a daily basis or what I'm
going to a grocery store like Fiji
that's my go to long each year our arrow
head is what you're saying spring when
I'm going on water grocery store because
I love Fiji water it has a very high
silica content and silica makes water
extremely smooth that that's what it is
there see and I can tell you something
before this is confirmed I thought I was
crazy when I would think about the idea
that Fiji tasted smooth to me yeah
because that's it that would be the
first word that I would describe it as
and I you know I didn't I didn't know
any of this but it does to the palate
and you're met you're like this why does
this taste like silky smooth I knew that
already and then she has the reason the
course this water has one of the highest
silica content whatever been found in
silicon really car silica and that's a
mineral it's a natural occurring middle
I love it she's yeah how do you say that
in German again Cheers post post blow it
host
how do I do that thing you're doing so
when I when I compared to your
filtration systems they are both are
room temperature but it feels that
features more refreshing
yeah this tastes like dog shit it has
more mineral content hundred percent so
the mineral content gives you that that
the ranch give me a line think about a
soup without salt right right your
minerals it's like
a blend recycling and you want a little
salt to kick off the soup it's the same
with water no water with no mineral
content what it's like in your palate
flat and it makes you thirsty err yeah
like you just drank our house will that
was our house well you're free sorry
like apologizing shitty water it's
totally different you can measure you
can measure the middle content by TDS
torrid soft solids and this water is a
key reserve of 222 le tap a lot of
people will surprise no between 240 Diaz
purified water companies maximum of 40
TDS when you see like what like one of
the voters and people think they're
getting very smart when they're drinking
that water
um yes I Jennifer Anderson it's actually
owned by coca-cola yes people don't know
that a lot of people drink that water
but don't know it but they are putting
on their labels and it's electrolytes
and everybody's like a cool and I have a
boy I want electrolytes yeah la mine
comes more electrolytes then weight
smart the smart water so that's what a
smart water yeah that's that nonsense
you buy it Trader Joe's yeah yeah so
they add electrolytes to smart water any
electrolytes but in very small amounts
and that is obviously cool thing that
people don't understand like whether
they edit electrolytes but they don't
tell you how many Fiji water has way
more electrolytes oh wow no more I mean
Europe there's lots of natural springs
everywhere I feel like that's a very
euro thing like I know my family we go
to a place called javis which is like on
the border whereas in Austria and
Hungary some Naturals like Europeans
love their natural job we swim in it you
drink it you bathe it - very euro I
really this has something to do with the
culture in Europe the course like yeah
dress it bathing in it so spire is are
very famous all over Europe
so people went to the spyrius back in
the days that's what I'm still doing it
for health benefits and they want to
make sure yes right
they want to treat themselves on water
embedding or even by drinking
therefore they understood the concept
that water is extremely important that
is actually the invention of bottled
water
the first invention was the first
bottled water came from spa areas as
medication because we are not invented
right people have went to the spire is
to get health again or like to have a
health product because the water has a
lot of minerals in it like cards
magnesium all this kind of minutes what
is extremely good for you when the
people were too sick to it
this part people started to bottle the
waters and sent them over to the sick
people Wow medication was invented
bottled water was in there Wow amazing
now these days a lot of bottled water is
more like hydration just hydration right
but back in the days the history of all
bottled waters actually medication do
you have a number that you try to hit as
far as consumption per day do you try to
um it really depends what you're doing
it depends what kind of exercise you're
doing so write me as a restaurant person
who walks around the restaurant all the
time I did the SNA 25 thousand steps on
Mother's Day obviously yeah what is that
equal game well it was excited miles or
me out something like this yeah yeah we
were slightly busy I drink a lot of
water but I'm trying and this is the key
as well drink the whole time and not
just think or I drink a gun in the
morning a drink a gallon in the yeah you
much it that doesn't work you need to
hydrate yourself all day I know that is
the key about modern water and drinking
water do not think you can hide it
yourself
Thanks can't play you know the water
shimmers in the room as well and he was
able yes here is an gallons in real
hours yes pretty crazy and I wanted to
tell you a little story well it's kind
of like a sad story yeah what happened
here in California somebody had a big
game in a radio show how much water you
can drink in one hour
ah here and that didn't work out well
now someone died right yeah so this
person were able to drink I think twelve
bottles of half liters so 12 liters of
water in one hour and the whole was the
whole game was like hey try to drink so
much water in this hour and then don't
worry they don't pee and winner we there
was a weenie tenderize right yes three
hours later she died Wow course you can
sample too much water into your body
your cells were like literally like
overspent of it blowing up
I'm completely drowned from inside oh my
god that is very sad so please guys no
over it I know don't overthink it don't
bring too much water
no there's really possibilities to
obviously not drink enough water
whatever definitely my parent that other
way are as well now I actually went to a
urologist a few years ago and I asked
him because I how much water should I be
drinking and it goes however much you
feel if you feel thirsty very often
exercising and I was like oh I thought
there's this rule that I have to have
eight ounces every two hour whatever
bullshit because that was a thing I feel
if you use it right I tell you to drink
item you have to have managers per day
or something like yeah that's when
you're sitting in a filling and it's
stock you don't need to so much water
then people obviously work on the street
okay so it really depends what you're
doing people who are exercising
extremely having like jobs like
somewhere where they like move the hotel
needs way more water yeah then people
were sitting the whole day yes what do
you normal throughout the key is drink
water that's the most important thing do
not start to drink sodas even when
you're thinking now this is made 90
percent of water but let's say said all
the calories hidden when I would use it
question now that brings us to our soda
question Lacroix Lacroix Lacroix I don't
know how you pronounce what is that
water or exact so my husband seems to
think it's more water than soda they are
somewhat it's like vitamin waters for
they even claiming themselves that this
is water let's face it vitamin water
soda sugar and sugar one yeah yeah no I
didn't write any what about this zero
calorie zero that's like Sevilla Lacroix
like are those water I mean they're
obviously there's there's a carbonation
and it would you like me to get wine
within my plan in combination to it yeah
this can happen this is totally normal
some bottled water companies are doing
this for example non Valley Springs are
very good water from America I love that
water it's a still it's a still spring
and they're adding combination to it the
same actually with some Pellegrino same
thing we know it's a still water oh it
is and they're adding them and they're
adding the combination to it you will
not find a sample to be no as a still
version on the planet the corner marking
themselves as a sparkling water right
there
adding actually co2 to it Wow Wow
so that actually is your drinking water
I mean water water water yo Kelly yeah
but I talked a little bit about the
other I think you can actually try
tinnitus one yeah and I set the cool
storm maybe you can hear it when I'm
open the bottle it I feel yeah I still
water but still something happened right
there now I may not use the same glass
as I drank my Fijian because that would
be contaminating with water flavors is
that right
well the naturals right they could be
mineral residue that's right look at
what obviously mix it but suddenly you
look at anything is happening what when
you look at this glass now very few
glass before by the way this
conversation I'd be like throw the shit
out this is bad yes like that's always
something going on here yeah and there's
bubbles they'll have any balance still
water so let's see what's happening when
I'm shake this bottle because it's a
still water and I'm not just the only
water Swami in America I'm actually the
David Copperfield of waters I can do
some magic with us as well okay so I can
turn this into milk ah let's see looks
clear to you yeah everything is good
here we go right oh wow that's a mineral
bath dude now I feel like I have seen
that's crazy man anything like very
slowly right here yeah it disappears
it's actually not the minerals
what is it it's not combination of
minutes why do you think I've come um
think about a silicon can it be no
bubbles no air officio to this car
vision oxygen oxygen oxygen the water
has a higher oxygen content than all
waters Elvin found in Denmark
that's reason the lab was so awful at
this and said like what the hell is
going on here and they found out is
Gilda what I said it's a I spring in the
Danish language they found out that this
is a very very old spring water around
seven thousand five year old what they
have in this class and the cool thing
about this is that our cold water hoots
more oxygen than warm water does that's
reason sometimes New York in the
wintertime when you open the tap water
is sometimes cloudy as well and that's
what I made in hotels where that type of
thing happens and I go never not
drinking this shit yeah it's not
immediately I saw exposed to extremely
high temperatures outside yeah yeah
that's the reason this water turns into
this very cloudy cloudy I'll take a
brand
taste-wise any heads-up on what we're
going to experience as opposed to the I
always say as so McGee would be a bet
somebody went on without you right away
what do you think what the taste would
be okay so I think you should discover
if you see something and be honest maybe
you'll see like some people have a hard
time to just divine teaching versus
gilded so she is going to choose oh my
god no totally different totally
different
especially the aftertaste
the applicator is very distinct it
smells like Europe it reminds me of
going to like a thermal bath or mineral
bad whatever it with my parents that
Fiji still has a much more like when I
do it right after especially a much the
smoothness it still stands out as very
different it does have like that any or
whatever I don't know how to describe it
aftertaste right you like all better
there's our minerals yeah definitely
yeah the sodium colleges very high up
the TDS is now 400 no it's almost a
double of the mineral content of
hitching and interesting what I think
especially about the aftertaste of skill
that has like this slightly earthy notes
to it like think about a mushroom or
something like this that's for me the
strangest taste of his Gilda I spent in
China last year in a big water tasting
competition and I had to taste 80
different waters blind like they they
gave me just the glasses like this mmm
and then drink it and then I had to
quote like what I think about the water
they gave me a skilled and I I knew
right away it says yeah you did yeah I
had 100 percent right away I gave four
hundred percent or hundred points to a
skilled as well because for me it's one
of the best waters I ever taste real how
I for me it's just like there's so much
characteristic and I love the idea about
the oxygen level as well that this water
turns into like the slightly milkiness
to it it's just mind-blowing water
that's a meant to be clear did you say
this right Alan you can get it three or
four dollars yeah arrow arrow on door
well big WOW let's get that it's pretty
cool I mean that's a really cool thing I
think it's a very exciting
price point pure an experience in other
words somebody wants to try this like
it's three or four bucks right
definitely dude we're not talking about
like yeah I had waters for over seventy
five dollars already what the most
expensive water i ever drunk it's
hundred thousand dollars come on
and if this was Diplo into chains when
you can go with Diplo into change yes
you can see it for G magazine the most
expensive shifts or just dig did that
come out or why 100 great see if you can
see it almost eight million clicks
already module it's hilarious
either where's our um yeah and actually
it's from California yeah dog so it's
kind of generally do Rio Rancho its way
it's Beverly Hills 908 tool ah silly
fifty white diamonds on the cap that he
really to expand right sailor water
itself is very good as well and but
obviously this is more like a funny cool
yeah yes greater like crazy play like
diamond water
I know if you watch that reality show
the shot yeah like can you can you in
few does it matter if you in five use
water with dynamic variables yeah when
you believe in something that's a very
diplomatic answer from Marley I'm like
it's all about minerals for me it's for
me a little scientific fact that water
has metals dissolved yes of course it
comes from the disses rounds what does
Tara fascinating what's up with Hilden
what's that's our next one yeah our next
one so we need to save some glasses oh
yeah the other way Gilda okay how do you
say water champion in German services
champion devatas champion yeah so here
is a sparkling water and this is the
official water of the Queen she drinks
this water all the time this is the
green water the Queen's water and is it
where's it from from England as fuck it
is Romania and you have to be a little
careful because when you're drinking too
much chilled water your arms suddenly
will do like this
yeah I do see a forest in there so now
love all bubbles and they're bigger they
look like they're big bubbles mm this
bubbles and again like in the beginning
everybody watched me looking at the
glass and now you guys doing this as
well because you can already see okay
obviously we're talking about a
carbonated water and the Palash what I
would say to it right now it's pretty
big interesting fact about this fortress
that the carbonation levels actually
very low but it's just like some big
bubbles involved in that water but it's
not like this progressive like maybe I
Gerolsteiner from Germany or something
we know what has like tons of yeah I
hate tons of bubbles
this is like gently spa yeah well she's
a queen man she is cheers whoops whoops
I love it see it to me this is so
European to American bottled waters I
mean the sparkling waters never taste
this subtle and the cool thing about
this is a homeowner I am telling you
right away as well what's actually in
here and this is kind of sad that mostly
the torrefied water companies especially
again they don't tell you at all what
they adding right TSS right away
magnesium content 1.7 calcium 97 sodium
7.7 chlorine 16 fluoride 8 to 12 degrees
is 0.02 so it's super low what it should
be in water because flood is not really
something what you want to want to drink
the whole time and total solids 312 so
they're adding this right away honestly
I think the biggest iOpener at least for
me and I think I imagine for people
listening is the idea that reading that
there's things in your water it doesn't
equal automatically or in any way
necessarily bad thing I think every one
of us probably who does no good oh
that's bad I am you want some mineral
fibers littles now so pure concept was
created silliness I I would drink a lot
more sparkling water if it weren't for
the saltiness the sodium content I find
that a lot of them are very salty yeah I
you can feel here Nick yes there will be
tough for you guys okay cuz those are
salty water area so would you consider
it so is this a nice option if you're
going to go for a sparkling water would
you say I think you'll know or maybe
yeah that's a I love feel of this things
volume content is very low it has a
salty the bubbles are very tiny and like
not like this progressive in your palate
despite can easily shut down this bottle
and it's not like that you're like yeah
yeah feeling like blowing up right away
now can I ask you how you have a water
menu that you offer yeah I feel like we
go to a lot of nice restaurants and
travel a lot and still even in high-end
restaurants I get the question
tap still or sparkling in other words
there's no other is the option thing
going to be developing more you think
restaurants I really hope so and I think
the first concept is that people need to
understand that they should drink more
water and finally in America but earth
water is the most consumed product now
and soda not anymore
so this is not amazing since to thank
guy bottled water is a number one
consumer product Wow and I love this I
love to hear this so obviously the
Americans understand that soldiers might
be not the best choice to drink and have
a journal finesse
well now the next step is to understand
that water is not just water yeah and
that they have big quality or
differences and again some waters are
coming from municipal source that's
actually nothing up then your tap water
so just drink tap and take the money
yeah or other waters coming from the
different regions of the world and
therefore they taste differently that's
all cuz I'm Emily did blow my mind
so let's see this is this a sparkling
water about at the spa keyboardist Vichy
Catalan Vichy Kalon is like the
arrowhead of Spain this is a number one
consumed sparkling water in Spain I've
been on Conan O'Brien as well for twelve
years ago Machel I did the water tasting
with him and he spit out that water
really yep it was like what the hell is
going on here it's like he didn't
believe me that this is coming from
nature Wow deer told I edit if I really
really yeah he thought I put like an S
Pen there and this is um this is
produced in Spain other words it hundred
miles up north from Barcelona whispering
okay so it's a spring it's a spring
water hundred-percent spring water
natural occurring comes right up 140
degrees Fahrenheit
why was the super hot spring what rise
up the water so we had a very cool
spring its gilded there's no a very hot
spring be she camera okay so let's see
the valley
yeah way more progressive than in the
Hilda are then you get hill right now
they are almost know
anymore is like there's really something
going on okay hmm oh my goodness
dude that is like an explosion of
saltiness for you a very bitter at the
end very salty
I also by the way what quality is it
because now I can I can it takes me back
now that I've had Stillwater in
traveling that has some of that taste is
that is that the sodium that it's the
sodium so sort of the first thing you
can you can get out of it how that the
granule is a small really strong and
this is right away we're talking about
over a thousand milligrams so salty yes
crazy the tds level is mind-blowing 3050
what it has more electrolytes in a
Gatorade going on we're doing what's
wrong with the reason they're so
hydrated maybe mainly I said the Spanish
people that's the reason they love this
water it's super hot outside in Spain
like here la yeah and so you're smelling
all the time yeah and when you're
sweating you're losing minerals yeah
that's pretty much because that's the
reason your sweat is salty
so when you compare a vision column and
drink this all the time you're getting
all your minerals back yeah well the
thing is what you cannot do and a lot of
people always say like oh just what
would water and then you'll be fine
that doesn't work as well because we all
know around two data sets negative to
dehydrate and then you will die after
two or three days and after two or three
weeks you will die because you didn't
have any food yeah so your body the most
minerals what your body needs comes from
food because and food there's way more
minutes actually than bottled water
right but bottled water is a cool thing
because the minutes are already
dissolved as water so it's very easy to
access it for your body demands because
you don't need really to process it and
let's think about iodine water
everybody talks about I cannot cry so
important airline that's a very it's
also very trendy right now it's very
trendy yeah it needs to be balanced and
some people saying I can't water you can
balance out your body with us because
your body is acidic because you're
eating so much acidic food and with an
alkaline water can balance out your your
body pH and then you are healthy
completely bullshit we do not believe in
that literally crap of course when you
drink water what we just
it goes into your stomach so your
stomach is up with fluids and yeah yeah
and the Senate float an extremely acidic
yeah so water will turn like this is
silly oh god that whole idea about or
you can balance out something with a pH
level is completely nonsense is your
body your body's highly is that your
stomach it has to break down after last
but this whole idea about alkaline water
do not have believe in this whole claims
by the way I can't believe we haven't
put this together yet with Martin here
do you know this clip yeah are you
thirsty all the breastfeed you how you
suck me dry it's a German man yeah he
also is there any fish but he's
providing a different that I wanted you
to know what kind of show you were on
like we've miss lechea
yeah I know II don't leave a radio okay
and when the bunnies had this water in
their mouth they also like oh it tastes
like deep yeah really like you like okay
yeah nobody says not just 10 times worse
than that really
hahahaha are going do we're going to do
why are we are what kind of cell excited
even thing just this year there okay
crazy one oh that blew my mind
mother all this start of a little taste
okay Wow let me ask you one question
before we move on so your palate I mean
you have to keep it so sensitive how do
you maintain your palate flavor your I
don't have any hot liquor no hard liquor
okay no cocktails I cannot stand contest
and I'm not gonna read for mycology over
that's the reason I don't like cocktails
yeah I don't drink hard liquor at all I
love wine and sparkling wines this is
like what I'm thinking when I'm like two
boosts up how about coffee no coffee
what is that for your palate towards
good I don't like the taste it's too
bitter for me maybe every coffee I
tasted so far is always just bitter and
I think my palate is just like involved
over so many years now to drink this so
much water that my pal is extremely
sensitive I want to ask them will you
grab from the fridge a Sevilla and
ilaqua thank you
the cool thing is well
is about drinking water and I had this
with the second I had a video it's on
YouTube as well with a girl from Zagat
and we're tasting different water huh
and she never drinks too much water and
you see in the end of the video
she's she feels like wasted she didn't
have any alcohol but she feels like she
started to a tickly and like he and and
it's like I got drunk and she's like I
had no but I feel like a little can sit
up here AB see and I think it was like
she might be as a person who doesn't
drink so much water all the time then I
exposed her to so much water and to
extremely high metal content water that
her body was like really reacting to it
it seemed like she was like honest
attitudes are normal sound anything you
know as you can see it on YouTube it's
kind of it's kind of funny and if he
really sits like in the camera thing I
feel really turned yeah yeah and water
has an impact on your body absolutely
it's greater it's cool
we brought this in because this is a
Christina made a good point like what
what is going on with these I know that
Lacroix exists I have to say I never had
it before it's so funny I know they're
BAE it's sodium free yeah and the CBO
one they're the one that he just put on
that table it has its the content on it
as well the funny thing is here they
don't tell you where this water's
actually coming from that's always a red
flag always fully okay what ingredients
Calvin well the Lacroix natural brand is
in Wisconsin and I assume that they they
make and bottle it everything there sure
are you sure it's from Wisconsin
yeah that's why that's the whole
argument for wine collaboratory Anthony
Warren Michigan is here this
distribution distribution right but I
don't tell you where the spring is
located all let's see so we don't know
if this is a spring water or purified
water
we have no clue gosh now we like this
beverage it's an alternative to soda we
don't drink sugar so extreme you shield
and the problem is when you're when
you're shutting something down I know
it's like refreshing but you cannot
really taste anything out of course when
you're chilling down a beverage in
general like in wines extremely the
taste aromas are like disappearing a
little
yes so let's see we should bring this on
a little temperature too so there's
definitely a smell right away yeah it's
like it has like a blueberry fruity
smell to it mmm tastes extremely sweet
hmm extremely sweet it has very tiny
bubbles you cannot taste water from this
recording it's not like there's there's
art officials and this is so many
artificial flavors yeah you can see it
as well huh it's like it's clear so it's
water yeah but obviously they are adding
some artificial flavors and yes they
said this is highly processed food why
that's not honest this is nothing else
than highly processed food so this is
stuff what you like when you like the
dick make for McDonald's it might be the
water to go oh my god oh and look there
look at their website where does the
water originate American brand using
water source from the u.s. ratified
Kerala days one day saying this this
means it's actually tap water look at
this I don't want to say it's using a
triple filtration system here we go
yep yep it's crap yeah it's stripped of
any mineral what I thought yeah now try
this vivia because my husband's
convinced that he's drinking water when
he's drinking zis is gonna be even
sweeter Wow sorry
keeping sure that's all we can do you
think I know a little sweetness okay
there's no artificial sweeteners no sure
yeah no other for sweetness but no other
flavors didn't that doesn't say that it
doesn't say that yeah now I mean Lacroix
was sweet to him Oh No very sweet
this is another one curious to see what
happened all that great oxygen looks
like I saw it all right that looks like
a soda what are you pouring this now
yeah it's naturally flavored US open it
right now
it makes stronger and you're gonna feel
better
wha-ha-ha it's not like a pebble
yeah that's like the smell it's like Doc
sherry I think yeah it's like Jerry yeah
like Cherie but it's natural it's all
natural
like they say natural flavor
that'll only make no artificial suffice
I apologize you have to say this on
camera and radial to good it's a good
review so far I don't know Jesus oh I
agree I agree oh yeah he loves it will
give you a case on the way I show so
what
Pepsi crystal there was a single yeah 15
low throws yeah it's like I need play
some it's gonna clean your palate or
something else yeah we champagne my
husband considers this drinking water do
you know that when he drinks this he
goes it's like drinking water this has
nothing to do with Walter guys what is
it what is emoted I mean I know you
don't know love it that's it's the same
what icing Pepsi crystal balls you have
to crystal what's a coke with no color
this looks like a soda with no color for
me very much what is this here's why
people are it's it's that it's the
there's no artificial added sweeteners
no sugar
so people are drinking this because it's
become a popular beverage because it's
like you're having a soda experience but
you're not getting that glucose spiked
you know I got it I got it disgusting
now I don't like them I don't drink them
but all we see there's like artificial
sweetener only half speaking about
obviously they need to do something with
something to to put some I think it's
religious like Jesus blesses it or some
love and it has whatever it's in there
but I know okay skywriting let's move it
along
he spit that out hilarious so I feel
it's like we she cannot is like a
beautiful moment with no choice yeah I
know
and then so far there's one two three
four five bottles that I've never even
heard of
that's what which is so cool and there's
two more that we haven't yet so we have
Roy as an expert from from Sylvania
okay now yeah it's my cousin Olivia are
these by the way available at patina or
are these or some of them vicious
available hoodies available features
available and is skilled as available
okay Roy you guys are the only people
in the whole United States who have a
body like since like ah what what nobody
else has Roy oh this is so amazing a guy
with Nia I know the owner very well here
owns a hotel in Slovenia and they found
off the spring is extremely old I have
to be a little careful actually as well
you should see it because it looks like
all okay yeah when I'm open this is
really like something going on oh yeah
and there's salt collected at the but
you can see and you know this one is
like this like and as it's how it's
naturally guess it's natural it's
wonderful you can actually see the
flakes the minerals on the bottom it
looks like a soda as well when I'm
pouring it yeah whoa cool yeah you can
see like wow residue snow right down
here what it's not how so don't worry
guys it's all good
all natural 100% it's like levia just
like the yeah I give the bottle like
what's happening here yeah what is going
on now is it that the mineral level is
so high that that's what the flakes are
yes but it's still safe to drink yes
totally fine it's from a spring I just
said you nice Cheers Oh Cheers
oh here we go I guess you get to the Oh
No
just as beautiful as German oh my god
hmm oh my goodness
I love this you know when I go to
Hungary I feel like this is the kind of
stuff that when you ask for sparkling
this is what you get you get this
actually it does it is like distinctly
the the high sodium feels to me European
yeah but there's something else in that
water
yeah not just the sodium there are very
metallic taste to it mm-hmm
and this water has their highest Alana
magnesium content whatever been found in
a spring water Wow
what do you think the TDS Service office
I mean let me recap a little bit pitchy
222 TDS yeah it's Gilder was far no
tedious here then we went back to 312
Vichy 3063 now what is right now that
5,000 won yeah I fell twice is right
here well yeah I would go even higher 7
because of I mean look how active that
water is the European one oh yeah I know
that's my employ yeah but this is again
now not for hydration anymore
so ROI is a water and they even
marketing direct this it's not like a
water you will drink on a daily basis
because it's so loaded with minerals and
this is so heavy in your palate as well
it's like you kind of drink really a lot
of this I was going to say when at the
whole point doesn't it
don't these levels affect how you're
tasting food the other words regular
everything yeah when you're drinking a
Roy and you try to taste like food right
next to it
forget it yeah the food will be
tasteless suddenly because this water
has so overwhelmed you it yeah it's all
events you cool thing about Roy is just
put a little drops into our oyster I
mean like noise is really amazing and
here something really it wholly changed
noise are feeling so that's pretty cool
that's amazed at what I like for a
dietary restriction that's like we
calling it in Europe healthy waters yeah
they're in Germany they would have a
medication label of it they would yes he
is considered to be a health water well
I have different regulations in Germany
and this is I think where the American
market really needs to step up their
game a little bit when it comes to
bottled water the regulations are very
strict when it comes to a bottled water
in Germany and the labeling as well yeah
and the government is saying like buy
some waters there's a brand from Korres
called bond AXA member nax are spelled
in a regular basic for a qu a yeah AXA
and they said like the German government
no wait a minute that's like purified
water Bonica means good water you cannot
label this Wow so they misspelled aqua
AQA on purpose that they can label
product oh wow the regulations are very
strict now but I think it's good I want
it for the person listening or watching
this how can they this is like an
obviously intriguing topic
learn more like is it should they go to
your site like what do you reckon if I
go to my site you can you can come to
patina obviously yeah I know what it
tells what happened about between on a
daily basis and we have this beautiful
water menu when I brought a small link
over here so this is the patina water
menu we have 22 4 million waters and
every water has like two pages and you
can literally like see Wow a little
taste profile of that water a story of
the water the pds compaines and actually
what's in there and then
price so and this goes like 222 familiar
waters what we're offering right now
this is incredible
Dinah Lee is coming up in July we will
have a water tasting based on our based
on our Dinah lay menu as well so three
different waters paired to your dishes
wait how much is the ROI the Slovenian
yeah this is the tricky part
so Roy you kind of ecstasy in America
but retail would be around $25 okay I'm
going what is this last one here that we
see what is that some hunger looks like
it I should I read that's 400 - my
favorite oh so is there like hatred and
contempt and we had I put that in a lot
of laughs that will be amazing and you
should we should all get a new guest
yeah okay okay this is this is a special
in-game thing very special again thank
you so much thank you sir I like the Roy
I really like this Roy is actually
pretty cool and I have the sometimes in
water tastings as well what I do and
people always stick to Roy yeah they
always like this a really cool water by
looking it's so unique it's so yes but
they're saying like I really love that
water
it's a I also like the level of the
bubbliness
I like the sodium content I feel like oh
no so got a lot of pizzazz yes the Queen
likes a duller sparkling water or
interesting English let's see the
Hungarian this is a still water again
again really but it has a little middle
content you okay it's called Mira yeah
I'm Gary oh and so that's just such
thesis I guess you get to choose that's
all about it then pulse again she's dead
okay let's see mm-hmm that is whoa
horrible that is just terrible
what is going on I'd even think that as
well that is Vettes of water or salt
water
yeah that that is garbage
what is that terrible little sulfur
don't you want some Zvi Oliver I asked
you one day vegan says 7,000 - its
milligrams of sulfur
oh let me see that can I see the ball
where is there bottled water like iced
tea Tiesto before you see the play
Oh TDS level VBS level though is high
yeah in the thousands it's gotta quit
8,000 8,000 entire ten I'll go 16 15 now
hideous it's but but in Hungary we have
a lot of Springs and there's a lot
answer you and me'll a convenience store
I want get bottled water like you're
just visiting you grab that off the
shelf now that's the menu area you're
getting out of tech here fuck so that's
the reason again guys water is not just
water water has taste and even here I
know a lot of purified water again
filling everything out of there they
creating charming voice that everybody
sings ours all tastes the same
yeah they all taste the same oh you see
now here they're sort of what I brought
something realized holy shit yeah what
has taste
I could write somebody unquote of Aisha
Massa I've never seen this one on that
shit that looks awesome
I was disgusting no you're sure yeah
this is so much upsetting water it's
terrible I mean and when I go to when
I'm in Budapest I always order Ashwin
bees which is sparkling water and they
definitely don't bring that shit they
bring their own they bring stuff similar
to I would say the Spanish one but I
want to like that's a Hungarian like it
to recap table one of the things to like
two basic like advanced yourself in this
nasty ash for spring water glacier water
or what correct
mineral water mineral level it will
phase on the bottle and it's this is
really the key guys always when you're
going to the grocery store and do it
with your kids do it with your family
it's kind of yeah yeah like buy several
bottles of water but make sure they are
all coming from a natural resource yeah
could then they will taste differently
and have them side by side do not show
them down happen side by side in
different classes and really taste them
through and then sudden you will realize
holy shit water has taste yeah yeah it's
from Earth I mean you think about it
it's tell me another earth we should be
thankful that we can drink all this kind
of cool different waters that we have
access to clean water we're going to get
blue bands on that and let's face it as
well there are millions of people who
don't have access to clean water their
topic for me as far as of water so murky
because everybody knows I have like so
many different cool waters and some
people think I'm the most hydrated
personal planet but they're yeah
millions of people are millions of the
excess and I think we should all honored
that we have access to clean water and
we should help people who don't have
access yeah what are the work for
example I'm supporting the Matt Damon
foundation and I'm trying to raise money
all the time too to help other country
is that is that his water org yes with
Matt Damon yeah he's big on that right
leg and I think it's a great thing what
he's doing there and I'm supporting them
even my home page there's a link that it
can spend some money and and I think
it's a good thing to do yeah so super
cool this was the most mind-blowing
thing I you know you think it but you
don't think about water I mean I mean I
don't I just consumed it eventually yeah
this was out in California we had for
the last five years a big drought
finally yeah we are out of the drought
right but I think that doesn't mean we
can waste water again right so this is a
point as well what I like to do with my
water menu I want to give water a value
that people understand hey there's a bit
more than than just water yeah and maybe
I could start to rethink my use of water
as well and maybe when I'm washing my
teeth don't have the tab open the whole
time just close it even California storm
a drought right now yeah but still we
need to save water because the summer is
coming trust me in two years we are back
on throughout is a very big drought
problem again
we have to save water for the future
generations and therefore let's all
drink enough water that's the key guys
do not drink sodas drink enough water
but please be considered as well what
you're doing with water yeah very good
Martin resey reset reset reset I just
got a giant personal journey just kind
of really I don't know we see our IESE
oh is it that way RI es um anyway a web
site is a Martin - reset right mm-hmm
comm you can go to patina in downtown
Los Angeles and actually see Martin in
the flesh and experience the water menu
and actually you know I think this is
really cool try out different waters and
and and see if you guys can experience
what we did here today it's a very very
eye-opening giving you can take a class
from Martin he can that's what I'm
saying you can't fight a class achene oh
yeah call me up shoot me an email
I'm always happy to hydrate people oh my
gosh thank you so thank you so much for
coming I know that was cool very cool
this is a h2 flow signing off and yeah I
got a I got a song for us so let me see
what he put anything not the water Jamie
and keine vas the transmission of a
search engine as is Nick Nick there
missed nice ta ya dere nine
that's not does he like you listening
goes ah see on the next one
alright here we go first I'm going over
the new bridge
[Music]
oh my god we played a party like 2420
lately when we probably went green only
21 when we only when you come there only
20 green of
Oh
[Music]